The bouquet of bell-shaped organisms you see in the middle of the screen right now are Vorticella.
In their youth, these protists are swimmers,
moving around to gather food and grow.
But as adults, Vorticella like to settle down,
using their long stalks to attach to bits
of rock, algae, or even animals.
Of course, sometimes multiple Vorticella find
the same prime real estate.
But when you’re small, it’s easy to share
space, and that is why you’ll find groups
of vorticella like this one.
It’s not technically a colony.
Think of it more as a community of like-minded
individuals.
And today, we are going to join them.
They may not seem to have the most exciting
lifestyle, I hear that.
But even in the microcosmos, constancy comes
with its own small thrills.
So today, we’re going to stick with these
Vorticella for 12 minutes of unedited footage
and get to know them better while also meeting
some of their strange visitors.
We’ve been visited several times now by
this delightfully blue blob that kind of resembles
a whale thanks to its relatively large size
and oceanic hue.
Of course, it is not a whale, but it is one
of our favorite giants of the microcosmos:
Stentor coeruleus.
Like vorticella, Stentors are ciliates.
And while this stentor is swimming freely,
they are known to attach to surfaces as well.
These attached stentors will take on the distinctive
trumpet shape that they are known and named
for, making them look like a larger, more
exaggerated form of the vorticella’s bell shape.
One of the striking movements you’ll notice
happening again and again is that rapid contraction
of the vorticella whenever they are touched.
This movement is likely a protective maneuver,
allowing the organisms to evade predators
and adapt to turbulent waters.
This movement is created by a thin fiber inside
the stalk called the myoneme, which contracts
rapidly into a coil.
This movement is very fast, as you probably
have been witnessing, but watch carefully
and you might be able to see some of those
tight coils as the vorticella contract and
relax again.
In the upper left corner here, you can see
what looks like a cross between a spider and
the Millennium Falcon.
Now again, it is of course neither of those
things.
This is a nauplius.
When Otto Friedrich Müller first observed
the nauplius in the 18th century, he thought
it was its own species—just one of those
strange, adult organisms of the microcosmos.
But eventually scientists understood that
this organism is actually the early larval
stage of some kind of crustacean.
And in about a minute, we will see one of
the crustaceans it might grow up to become.
This crustacean is a cyclops, one of the possible
creatures that the earlier nauplius might
eventually grow into.
The inspiration for its name is obvious: what
else could you name an organism that only
has one large eye?
The cyclops of the microcosmos is, as we will
see, a bit obtrusive.
But it is relatively harmless to us—that
is until and unless they become host to parasites
like the Guinea worm, which can do harm to
humans.
Returning our attention to the vorticella,
while their adult forms don’t move around
much, they are still able to gather food ranging
from bacteria to smaller protists.
They do this using the cilia around their
mouth, waving around the small hair-like structures
to create currents that will drive food into
their mouths.
You may have noticed some smaller organisms
swimming and grazing amongst the vorticella.
Many of these are rotifers, trying to find
the green algae you can also see zooming around.
Or you can see them munching on the bacteria
and fungi that form the biofilm that the Vorticella
have attached themselves too.
It is always so strange to realize that rotifers
are multicellular animals, while vorticella
are single-celled organisms.
And yet rotifers are usually smaller than
their structurally simpler neighbors.
Like other microbes, vorticella are found
in aquatic habitats all over the world.
But in 2012, a group of scientists found evidence
of a vorticella in a very strange location:
inside the 200 million year old fossil of
a leech cocoon from Antarctica.
Yes, the vorticella-like organism was also
long dead, preserved in the polysaccharides
and fibrous proteins that made up the prehistoric
cocoon.
Ciliates may be easy for us to find in our
own microscope samples, but these kinds of
fossilized remains are much more rare because
their soft bodies make for bad fossils.
The uniqueness of this kind of discovery is
matched by just how striking the similarities
are between the fossilized organism the scientists
found and the modern day Vorticella you can
see here.
Even in the fossil, you can make out the distinct
bell-shaped body and helical stalk that so
closely resemble these Vorticella, living
right now before our eyes
I don’t know much about microbial etiquette,
but this cyclops
does seem kind of rude, like it’s just trying
to push its way through the vorticella.
Then again, maybe the vorticella are the rude
ones, taking up all this space?
Or maybe we shouldn’t be pushing our human
sense of etiquette onto microbes.
Whatever the answer, the vorticella seem to
be holding their own quite well here.
While the vorticella contracted tightly in
response to the cyclops earlier, you can now
watch as they extend back to their normal
configuration.
You might even see some of the tight coils
in their stalks in the moments before they relax.
Vorticella were first described by the creator
of the microscope Antonie van Leeuwenhoek
himself in 1674.
But you know who doesn’t care about that
distinction?
This cyclops, who is back for round two.
For all the smaller organisms that dart in
and out, and for all the larger organisms
that rudely barrel through them, the vorticella
just rolls with the punches.
After 12 minutes of this, I’m starting to
feel like maybe I could learn a thing or two
from these little troopers.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you especially to all of these people
who support this show on Patreon.
They are the reason this small team of people
can make this show.
And we are really happy and grateful to be
able to do it.
If you’d like to join them, you can go to
patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James, you can check out Jam
& Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.